- Would you rather have
earthworms for eyebrows
or clams for ears?
Kelly's really thinking
about it, you guys.
I need you to see her face right now.
(laughter)
(relaxed music)
Hi, I'm Heben from Another Round
and I'm here with the
multi-talented Miss Kelly Rowland.
Mrs. Kelly Rowland.
- Hello.
- Mrs. Kelly Rowland...
- Witherspoon.
We're about to do some pew-pew-pew
rapid fire questions
and I'm so excited to be talking with you.
Kelly, are you ready for this jelly?
(laughs)
I'm so sorry, I had to do it.
I could not not do it.
♫ Girl, I think I'm ready for your jelly
- Ey!
Random question number one.
Do you immediately change
into super soft clothes
when you get home?
- Yes.
- Like, is it immediately I'm
taking my pants off situation?
- [Kelly] Yes.
I love nice pajamas.
- Ooh.
- Yes, I will buy pajamas
- Okay.
- So fast.
Oh, I love pajamas.
- Is there a TV theme song you
ever find yourself singing?
♫ We're moving on up
(laughs)
- Yes!
Okay, we have some silly
would you rather questions.
- Okay.
- Would you rather have
earthworms for eyebrows
or clams for ears?
Kelly's really thinking
about it, you guys.
I need you to see her face right now.
(laughs)
She's deep in thought.
- Oh God.
I think I would rather have
earthworms for eyebrows.
- Okay.
- Because I like thick eyebrows.
- [Heben] The thick fuzzy?
- Mm-hmm.
- Yes!
I'm glad it's quote unquote in right now,
but like, every brown girl is like,
"Hey, where were y'all
at like a few years ago?"
- Yes.
- You're like, I'm on it.
- Would you rather
have your deepest,
darkest secrets come out
every time you fart
(giggling)
or have spaghetti for pubes?
Again, deep in thought.
- Spaghetti for pubes.
- Wait, that was so easy.
Talk to me about that.
- Spaghetti for pubes 'cause you know
with spaghetti you can just like
(plucking)
take them off.
(laughs)
- So what about like the texture?
I feel like it could get kind of weird
damp, wet situation?
- No, because just like hair,
you can take them hoes off.
(laughs)
- What are some of the songs
that remind you of your childhood?
- Songs that remind me of my childhood:
Janet Jackson's
♫ When I think of you
To Whitney Houston's
I'm Your Baby Tonight.
That was actually the
song that I auditioned to
to be in the group.
- Really?
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Oh my God.
- Michael Jackson's Keep it in the Closet,
which is where I saw Naomi
with all of that hair.
- Yes!
- And I actually used to
put on my mama's scarves,
you know, to mimic hair.
- Absolutely, been there.
- And just twirl, oh my God.
(laughs)
Oh, love.
- Do you ever feel nostalgic?
What do you feel nostalgic for?
- When I lived at home with my mama.
- Really?
- Yes, because I didn't have
much of a care in the world.
You know, when you're a kid,
you just have that moment
to where it's just innocence.
And I think that more people
should embrace innocence.
We need to operate off of kindness.
A kind love, agape love.
We don't do much of that these days.
- That was so beautifully-put.
Yes.
- Sorry.
- I love that.
- I didn't mean to give it to you.
- Do not apologize!
Are you kidding me?
That was delightful.
(relaxed music)